[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام احييكم وهذه الخامسه
مشاهدينا نبدا بالعناوين
[تصفيق]
امميه لايران باستخدام السلاح الاعدام ضد
المعارضه وتحذيرات من اعدامات جديده وشيكه
مع اوروبا
جديده
عمل الفتيات بالمراكز التجاريه وتعوز
باغلاق مراكز التجميل خلال 10 ايام
طرح مذكرات الامير هاري بالاسواق
مشاهدينا سنبدا الخامسه من ايران حيث
انتقدت مفوضيه حقوق الانسان التابعه للامم
المتحده احكام الاعدام ضد المحتاجين هناك
قال مفوض حقوق الانسان قال ان النظام
الايرانيه استخدم عقوبه الاعدام كسلاح
لنشر الخوف بين المواطنين والقضاء على
المعارضه اضاف ان محاكمات الاعدام تتم وفق
اجراءات لا تستوفي المعايير القانونيه
الدوليه وتصل الى حد عمليات قتل بتفويض من
الدوله وسلب الحق في الحياه
قبل ذلك اعلنت منظمه حقوق الانسان
الايرانيه انه لا يزال 109 مضاد ظاهرين
على الاقل معرضين لخطر اصدار او تنفيذ
احكام بالاعدام في ايران اكدت المنظمه
الحقوقيه الايرانيه ومقرها النرويج في
احدث تقرير لها اكدت ان النظام الايراني
يحاول متعمدا اشاعه الغموض حول قضايا
المعتقلين عبر تصريحات متناقضه في ملفاتهم
وخاصه المحكوم عليهم بالاعدام بعد المنظمه
المجتمع المدنيه الايراني والدولي الى
تسليط الضوء على القمع المكثف للنظام
الايراني اثناء الاحتجاج والاستجواب
واصدار احكام جماعيه
هذا وقد اصدرت النيابه العامه في ايران
تعليمات للشرطه الايرانيه للتعامل وبحسم
ضد خلع الحجاب وفقا تلفزيون ايران
انترناشونال كان النظام الايراني وتحت
الضغط الاحتجاجات الشعبيه في البلاد حل
دوريات شرطه الاخلاق والتي كانت مسؤوله عن
تتبع لباس المراه
على كل المزيد معنا من مقر مجلس الشيوخ في
باريس ينضم الينا الان جيل بيرجيه وهو عضو
لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في مجلس الشيوخ
الفرنسي اهلا بك سيد جيلبس اسمح لي ان
ابدا بالاعدامات واخرها تم الاعلان عنها
الان اعدام ايراني جديد لاحد المحتجين كيف
تقيمين تقيمون هذه الاعدامات هل تعتبر
مرفوضه من اصلها كليا او انه لا يجب ان
تكون مترويه نوعا ما الحكومه الايرانيه في
التعاطي مع هذا الملف
يمكن سوق بلاي
يستخدمون الدين لغرض سياسيه وهذا سوف يؤدي
الى انكار انتماء هذا النظام للدين ونحن
هنا في فرنسا نطالب باستدعاء كافه سفراء
الاتحاد
[موسيقى]
الكثير من الاموال خارجه ايران من اجل
اعاده هذه الاموال الى الشعب الايراني
او اتخاذ مثل هذه الاجراءات التي تطلبونها
البعض كان يقول بانه ال- الدول الاوروبيه
بصوره عامه وفرنسا تحديدا ربما كانت تحاول
استرضاء النظام الايراني هل هذا واقعي
ليس هناك اي مرورنا في الموقف الذي نتبناه
حيايا
النظام الايراني نحن هنا في مجلس الشيوخ
نتبنا موقفا صار لمن والحكومه ايضا جددت
موقفها اثار وهذا هو الموقف الذي نتبناه
نحن ايضا ان تنمي الى المعارضه يجب تبني
موقف صار هذا النظام
الديكتاتور الذي يجب ان يغادر سلطه في
ايران هناك بعض التحركات من قبل برلمانيين
ان كان في النمسا ان كان في المانيا
وغيرها من الدول تتبنى قضايا معتقلين
بعينها هل تعتقد انه مثل هذه الخطوات
مجديه وهل هناك من يتبعها في فرنسا
المعتقلين الذين يدعمهم ونحن
نطالب همم السلطات بتحرك مننا نحسب دعم
المجتمع الدولي
ممثل السفاره الايرانيه اليوم الى وزاره
الخارجيه الفرنسيه وهذا يدل على ان فرنسا
والبرلمانيين الفرنسيين لا يؤيدون
الاستمرار في ترك هذا النظام الوحشي يعذب
وينفذ احكام الاعدام لانه يتمتع بنوع من
الديمقراطيه في ايران
ولكنه ايضا هذا الاستدعاء ايضا يؤكد انه
النظام لا يابا لا بتحركاتهم ولا باي
ضغوطات حتى الان مفروضه على النظام لانه
قبل ان
ان نبدا بهذا اللقاء كان هناك اعلان عن
اعلان جديد
حقيقيه ولا يمكن ان اصدق ان هناك امكانيه
للحوار مع هذا النظام من يتحاور مع
الايرانيين اليوم فقد روسيا وروسيا في
حاله حرب مع اوكرانيا من اجل الحصول على
مسيرته
لديها كثير من
المشكلاته
يدعم ايران
بلدان الخليفه تبتعد ايضا بشكل
ايران ليس هناك من دعم اوروبي وفرنسي
تحديدا لنظام الايراني ولكن هل التوجه هو
لتغيير نظام كليا تغيير فقط ام ماذا
يجب العوده الى
الديمقراطيه حقيقيه و ضروريه في هذا البلد
الشباب والنساء يطمحون لذلك هم يطمحون في
حياه يتمتعون في كنافه بالكرامه لا يمكن
ان يعيشوا في نظام يعذب والوضع الان اسوء
من ما كان عليه الحال في نظام الشاه
كان معنا اذا من مقر مجلس الشيوخ في باريس
جلبير روجيه عضو لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في
مجلس الشيوخ الفرنسي شكرا جزيلا لك على
هذه المشاركه
طبعا تتواصل في بروكس الفعاليات مؤتمر
الثوره الديمقراطيه الايرانيه بمشاركه
دوليه طبعا هذا المؤتمر دعت اليه منظمه
مجاهد خلق ومنظمه اللجنه الدوليه للبحث عن
العداله ومن هناك معنى مباشره نور الدين
الفريدي مراسل العربيه اهلا بك نور الدين
انت على الهواء مباشره هل تسمعني
نور الدين
اهلا بك
يعني لم اطرح السؤال ولكن اعتقد ان السؤال
العام والاول هو عما يطرح هذا المؤتمر
ربما من طلبات اييه توجه للاتحاد الاوروبي
او النت وتحديدا وهو لا يبعد كثيرا عن
اجتماعاتها
الطلبات التي تحدث عنها وشدد عليها
المتدخلون سواء كان من الجانب الاوروبي او
من الجانب الامريكي او البريطاني هي ان
الوقت قد حان بالنسبه للاتحاد الاوروبي
والدول الغربي بصفه عامه ان تبادل بعزل
النظام الايراني كليا على الصعيد
الدبلوماسي ان تسحب الدول الاوروبيه
سفراءها وتغلق بعثتها الدبلوماسيه ان همم
تامر باغلاق البعثات الدبلوماسيه
الايرانيات وترحيل الدبلوماسيه الايرانيين
لانهم مثل ما هو يوسف هناك في المؤتمر قال
بيتهم ينتمون الى وزاره الاستخبارات ان
يشدد الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات المتحده
وكندا العقوبات ضد النظام الايراني
الى الانهيار مثل ما تطالب هاته الثوره
الجاريه وان يد الاتحاد الاوروبي
والولايات المتحده وكندا الدول الغربيه
المعارضه الايرانيه على غرار ما فعلت في
العام 1979 عندما دعمت همم خميني ايه الله
خميني عندما قررت هذه الدول التخلص ورفع
يدها ورفع الغطاء عن النظام الشافي ذاك
الوقت بالنسبه لي المؤتمرين قد حان الوقت
بالنسبه للغرب ان يدعمه المعارضه
الايرانيه مثل ما دعم همم سقوط سقوط همم
الشيخ
نعم هاتي قضيه رئيسيه طرحت في غضون ساعتين
من النقاشات والكتاب الذي نشر بهاته
المناسبه عن البديل الذي يمكن ان يحل محل
النظام الايراني لان هناك مخاوف من ان هذا
البلد قد يتفكك لانه يتالف من شعوب عده
وكان هناك طبعا اجماع من حيث المتدخلين
لانهم اصدقائه يدعمون مجاهدي خلق على مدار
سنوات هم يرون بان المسجد الوطني للمقاومه
الايراني يمثل البديل وهذا البديل يجب ان
يكون ديمقراطيا يفصل بين الدين والدوله
يحترم حقوق الاقليات هذا الكلام هو كلام
المؤتمرين لكن المعروف خارج هذا المؤتمر
ان ال- ال- العديد من الشعوب الايرانيه
مثل همم مثل الاحوازيين مثل البالوش مثل
الاذريين ليس لهم وجود داخل المجلس الوطني
في كثير من المداخلات هم لهم مداخلاتهم
فعاليات
الا عن ايه عن المجاهدين خلق ولكن هذا
الامر قابل للتغير وهناك محاولات ايضا همم
تابعناها في وقت سابقا من الاوروبيين
يدعون فيها مختلف فصائل المعارض الايراني
سواء كان المجلس الوطني المقاومه او
الممثلين الشعوب الاخرى الى ايجاد نوع من
التحالف
لتقدم وان يكون لتشكيل البديل الحقيقي
المقبول والديمقراطي والمتعدد للنظام
الايراني
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
البحريه الامريكيه تعلن ضبط سفينه علمتنها
اسلحه قادمه من ايران الى اليمن
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه اعلنت البحريه
الامريكيه اعتراض سفينه صيد في خليج عمان
كانت في طريقها من ايران الى اليمن
القياده المركزيه الامريكيه قالت في بيان
لها قالت ان السفينه كانت علمتنها اكثر من
2100 بندقيه هجوميه ثم ضبطها في السادس من
يناير الماضي قال قائد القياده المركزيه
الامريكيه ان القوات البحريه ستظل يقظه في
الكشف عن اي نشاط بحري يعوقو حريه الملاحه
او يعرض الامن الاقليمي للخطر مشيرا الى
ان شحنه الاسلحه جزء من نمط مستمر لنشاط
ايران المساعسع للاستقرار
الى ذلك اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
عن مكافاه تصل لعشره ملايين دولار امريكي
لمن يدلي بمعلومات عن اثنين من
ممولين ليش يا حزب الله في لبنان دعا
برنامج مكافات من اجل العداله التابع
للخارجيه الامريكيه عبر تويتر دعا لتقديم
معلومات عن انشطه كل من على سعاده
وابراهيم طاهر
المصنفين كارهابيين دوليه
تركيا تواصلوا عرقله انضمام السويد الى
حلف الناتو في المقابل تصر الاخيره على
ضروره تعزيز روابطها العسكريه مع حلفائها
الغربيين طبعا تمهيدا للانضمام للحلف بناء
عليه تعمل ستوكهولم على ابرام اتفاقيه
عسكريه مع واشنطن لتحقيق تعاون اوثق مع
الولايات المتحده على الصعيدين الثنائي
وفي اطار حلف شمال الاطلسي حسب وزاره
الدفاع السويديه وزير الدفاع السويدي
جونسون افاده بان الاتفاقيه الجديده
ستسهل على القوات الامريكيه العمل داخل
الحدود السويديه من خلال توفير اماكن
لتخزين العتاب الدفاعي وكذلك القيام
باستثمارات في البناء التحتيه لتفعيل
الدعم بين الدولتين بالاضافه الى الوضع
القانوني للجنود الامريكيين في السويد
هذا وقد وقع الاتحاد الاوروبي
وحلفنيت اتفاق شراكه امنيه قال امين عام
حلف شمال الاطلسي يا ناس في مؤتمر مشترك
مع ممثلين الاتحاد الاوروبي قال ان الحلف
والكتله الاوروبيه يجب ان يستمر في تقويه
شراكتهما لمواجهه بوتن طبعا على حد تعبيره
نستمع
والاتحاد الاوروبي لتطوير الشراكه بيننا
منذ قرابه العام وساعه بعد اجتياح روسيه
لاوكرانيا في الرابع والعشرين من فبراير
التقينا هنا في مقر الناتو الرئيس بوتل
اراد ان يسيطر على اوكرانيا في ايام قليله
واراد ان يقسمنا ولقد فشل في الامرين معا
وبشكل واضح القوه الروسيه تم بحرها من قبل
القوات الاوكرانيه
النظام في موسكو يريد اوروبا مختلفه يريد
السيطره على جيرانه وهو يرى الحريه
والديمقراطيه كتهديد الله وسيكون لهذا اثر
البعيد ولهذا يجب ان يستمر في تقويه
الروابط بين اعضاء ويجب ان يستمر في تقويه
الشراكه بين النيته والاتحاد الاوروبي
ويجب مزيد دعمنا لاوكرانيا
شيكو على ان بلاده ستوا
صل تطوير الثالوث النووي والحفاظ على
جاهزيته القتاليه اشار خلال اجتماع الموسع
مع قاده الجيش الروسي الى ان الدرع النووي
كان ولا يزال الضامن الرئيسي لسياده روسيا
وسلامه اراضيها واضاف ان روسيا تعمل على
تشغيل مزيد من المقاتلات والقادفات واجهزه
الدفاع الجوي الحديثه ولفتاه الى ان الخطط
الفوريه تشمل توسيعه راسانه الاسلحه
الهجوميه الحديثه وتطوير المعدات
والتجهيزات العسكريه الى اعلى مستوى في
عام 20 23
قاعده
سنواصل تطوير الثالوث النووي والحفاظ على
استعداده القتالي لان الدرع النووي كان
ولا يزال الضامن الرئيسي لسياده البلاد
وسلامه اراضيها سنعمل ايضا على زياده
القدرات القتاليه للقوات الجويه ومن بينها
عمل المقاتلات والقاذفات في المناطق التي
تعمل فيها انظمه الدفاع الجوي الحديثه
وكذلك تحسين الطائرات بدون طيار
فوق التكلفه
قال لها سكرتير مجلس الامن الروسي نيكولاس
بتوجيف بان الصراع في اوكرانيا تحول الى
صراع بين روسيا من جهه ونيتو واضاف ان
الولايات المتحده والغرب عدت السلطات في
اوكرانيا لشنها هجمات ضد روسيا وتقطيع
اوصالها اشار ايضا الى ان الانسحاب
المفاجئ للولايات المتحده من افغانستان
كان غرضه التركيز على اوكرانيا وعلى
عسكرتك بالاسلحه التي تم نقلها من
افغانستان
ونبقى في اوكرانيا وفي ما يتعلق بالتطورات
الميدانيه تشهد منطقه بخمس في مقاطعه
دوناتس ضمن اقليم بس مواجهات عنيفه وفي
اخر التطورات قالت السلطات هناك طبعا هي
مواليه لروسيا قالت ان القوات الروسيه على
وشك السيطره الكامله على سوليدار فيما
افاد حاكم الاقليم بابلو كيرلانكو بتعرض
المنطقه لغارات روسيه عنيفه تسببت في
اصابه عده مدنيين بجروح خاصه
هذا وقد ابلغت بريطانيا عن اختفاء اثنين
من مواطنيها كنا في طريقهما الى بلده
سوليدار المحاصره في دونيسك وبحسب وسائل
اعلام بريطانيه فقد تم الابلاغ عن شبين
اندرو باشو وكريستوفر باري وكيلاهما
متطوعان يساعدان في اجلاء المدنيين
والجهود الانسانيه في اوكرانيا
قبل ذلك اقرت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه بان
القوات الروسيه وايضا مجموعات فاجنر حقق
التقدما تكتيكيا في سوليدار سيطره على
معظمها في الايام الاربعه الماضيه الوزاره
وفي بيان لها اليوم قالت ان روسيا وضعت
السيطره على سوليدار هدفا رئيسا لتطويقه
بخمه من جهه الشمال وتعطيل خطوط الاتصال
بين الوحدات العسكريه الاوكرانيه رغم ذلك
استبعدت الدفاع البارطانيه نجاح روسيا في
تطبيق قريبا مشيره الى ان القوات
الاخرانيه تحتفظ بخطوط دفاعيه مستقره
وتتحكم في طرق الامداد بالمدينه
بدوره يتحدث مسؤول عسكري امريكي بارز
لصحيفه ولستريد جورنال عن الاوضاع
الميدانيه في الداخل الاوكراني واصفا
المعارك في محيط باخمط بالوحشيه موضحا ان
كل طرف من الطرفين يقصف الاخر بالاف
القذائف يوميا واضاف العسكريه الامريكيه
ان لا تغير في منطقه قرسون متحدثا عن
تنازع لمناطق محدوده بين الجانبين الروسي
والاوكراني المسؤول الامريكي اكد ان
الولايات المتحده ستواصل ارسال الدفاعات
الجويه لاوكرانيا
المزيد معنا منك كيف مراسل العربيه حذيفه
عادل اهلا بيك حذيفه بدايه كيف تبرر
اوكرانيا هذا التقدم الروسي في تلك
المناطق
مساء الخير يعني طبعا المعركه الاعلى في
الان هي في سوليدار تحديدا وسوليدار هي
تعتبر جبهه باخوج يعني في خلال الشهور
الثلاثه الماضيه عندما نتحدث عن جبهه بخوت
نتحدث عن تقدم للقوات الروسيه في اتجاه
سوليدار ولكن الان القوات الروسيه اصبحت
تحاصر مدينه سوليدار التي تدافع عنها الان
القوات الاوكرانيه الهدف الرئيسي والاساسي
للقوات الروسيه والوجهه الاساسيه هي مدينه
باخوض طبعا بعد ان عجزت عن اقتحام هذه
المدينه والدخول مباشره اليها غيرت
الاستراتيجيه كما يقول القبراء العسكريون
الاستراتي التي همم الجديده هي عمليه حصار
مدينه باخم من الجهاد الاربعه لكي يتم ذلك
لابد من السيطره اولا على مدينه سلدار
وقطع الامدادات العسكريه عن القوات
المقاتله في باخوطه الوضع في باخوه الان
صعب جدا بالنسبه للقوات الاوكرانيه لان
ايضا المدينه نفسها هي محاصره من ثلاثه
جهات والجهه الوحيده التي يسيطر عليها
الاوكرانيون والتي فيها الطريقه
الاستراتيجي الذي يمكن من خلاله امداد
القوات الاوكرانيه هناك هو في مرمى نيران
القوات الروسيه فالوضع صعب جدا والامدادات
صعبه الوصول الى القوات الاخرانيه
المقاتله في مدينه سوليدار والجيش الروسي
يهاجم بشكل مستمر والشرس ويومي
على ماذا تقول اوكرانيا بانه الاسباب
الرئيسيه هي وراء مثل هذا التقدم بالنسبه
للروس بعد ان كانت اوكرانيا هي التي تتقدم
في بعض المناطق
نعم في الحقيقه اولا تم يعني تغيير
الاستراتيجيه وهو السبب اولا تم سحب بعض
القوات من اتجاه ضخم نفسها مدينه باخم
تحديدا اعني ايضا تم سحب بعض القوات من
ليس الشانسكو من اتجاه صفاته ومن
سيفردوسكو وتم تعزيز القوات في منطقه
سوليدار هنالك هدفين من ذلك اولا السيطره
على هذه المدينه لاحكام الحصار على مدينه
باكو هذا من جانب ايضا هنالك كما يقول
المراقبون والعسكريون يقولون انه هنالك
هدف سياسي اخر لان القوات الروسيه منذ
بدايه منذ اجتياح الاول وبعد ان السيطره
على هذا الشافع ومن الاراضي بعد ذلك اصبح
حتى تراجع والقوات الاخرانيه تتقدم
وتستعيد الاراضي لذلك هي سياسيا في حاجه
الى مصر همم باسرع ما يكون لذلك هي الان
تركز كل جهودها في هذه المنطقه طبعا ايضا
همم القوات الروسيه منذ فتره من الزمن
تركز على منطقه تونس ليه السيطره الكامل
على الكامل الحدود الاداريه لهذه المقاطعه
ما الذي تبقى من هذه مقاطعه تبقى باخموت
وتبقى اكرام الطورس كواصلوا معسكر المدن
الكبرى وبعض البلدان هل يعتبر هذا نوع من
الهزيمه بالنسبه لاوكرانيا في تلك المنطقه
تحديدا او ليس حتى هذه اللحظه
عسكريا يقول الخبراء العسكريون ان سوليدار
ليس لها اهميه استراتيجيه عسكريه ولكن
تكمن اهميتها في انها همم ستكون جبهه
جديده تضغط على مدينه ضخمه نفسها لذلك بعد
السيطره على سوليدار سوف يكون هنالك همم
يعني ضغط كبير على مدينه باخوه يمكن من
خلال سلودار التوجه الى اعلى والحصان
الكامل لهذه المدينه الاهميه الاستراتيجيه
وبالمقابل اذا ما سقطت باخ موت هل هذا
يعتبر نوعا ما بالنسبه لكيف همم هزيمه ام
انه لا التركيز بالنسبه لها سيكون في
اتجاهات اخرى او جهات اخرى ربما
نعم طبعا الجيش الاوكراني والرئي دائما ما
يتحدث وحتى في اخر خطاب لو قال ان كل متر
من الاراضي الاوكرانيه يعتبر بالنسبه لنا
خساره كبيره ولكن طبعا السيطره على باخوه
سوف تكون باخ مت هي معقل الجديد ومكان
تمركز جديد للقوات التقدم الى المدن
الكبرى اولا مصادر المياه
العذبه كذلك السيطره على كامل الحدود
الاداريه وبهذا تكون قد اعلنت روسيا
السيطره الكامل على دونيسك بشكل كامل لذلك
طبعا ستكون خساره كبيره بالنسبه للجيش
الاوكراني اذا ما سقط الضغط التي ستساعد
في التقدم نحو اكره متوسط
ومعنى من هناك رائد الاخضر اللي طلعنا على
اخر التطورات كيف هي الاوضاع رائد
الميدانيه
ما يصير ميسون مساء الخير بالفعل يعني ما
زالت القوات الخاصه الروسيه قوات بادنر
والقوات الشيشانيه اضافه الى قوات
نوغانسكا الشعبيه التي تتقدم من منطقه
لوجان يعني تخوض معارك ضاريه في بلده
سندار بلده سيدار
متاخمه لمدينه باخمت من الناحيه الشماليه
وباخبط مذكر دائما بانها تقع في شمال
مقاطعه
وصلت المعارك الى
دراوتها في وسط البلده حيث ان القوات
الروسيه الخاصه تدفع لقوات الاوكرانيه
للانسحاب من وسط المدينه الى المناطق
الغربيه لا تصل الامدادات الى القوات
الاوكرانيه بسبب قصف همم يعني المنظومه
الاستراتيجيه الروسيه عبر صواريخ بعيده
للامدادات العسكريه ان كانت بشريه او
بالاليات والعتاب عبر الطريق السريعه الذي
يمد القوات الاوكرانيه همم من باخمط الى
سوليدار فلا تصل الامدادات قطع
هل هناك من توقعات من قبل المراقبين ان
يكون هناك بالفعل انسحاب وربما على المدى
القصير في مده زمنيه يقال بانها ربما تكون
المده التي ستسيطر فيها روسيا على باخ موت
او لا المفاجات يمكن ان تحدث
كان اليوم مقارنه ما بين الانسحاب الاخير
من اخر معقل للقوات الاوكرانيه في
المقاطعه المتاخمه وهي لوكاند حيث نذكر
مدينه التي شانس كانت المعارك مشابهه لما
يحدث الان في سوليدار
وانقضى الليل واستيقظ الجيش الروسي على
بلده فارغه من الجيش الاوكراني انسحب
الجيش الاوكراني ليلا كان من المتوقع ان
ينسحب الليله الجيش الاوكراني من منطقه
سلدار الى منطقه او بلده مدينه باخمه
المتاخمه او الى المدن المجاوره لكنه ماذا
لا يقاوم واا بالفعل هناك همم يعني همم
تخمينات الانسحاب الجيش الاوكراني الليله
او هزيمه خلال يوم او يومين او ثلاثه
حتى الان همم على اشدها ام ماذا
المعارك بالفعل محتدمه في وسط المدينه وفي
المناطق الغربيه كما اسلفت ميسون وبالفعل
يعني اذا كان الجندي الاوكراني لا يملك
الذخيره والعتاده الذي يستطيع ان يقاوم
فيه
الامكانيات العسكريه الكبيره التي يتمتع
بها جيش الروسي والقوات الخاصه فظن بان
المقاومه صعبه ربما يصمد لفتره ولكن في
الحقيقه حتى الجانب الاوكراني يؤكد صعوبه
الموقف امام الجمهوريه
يعني اهميه بالغه وهو ان الصواريخ الروسيه
ايضا قصفت موقع
للقياده الالكترونيه للتواصل ما بين
المقاتلين على الجبهات وما بين القياده في
هذه القاعده التي اا يعني تنقل الانفصال
عبر اسمه
قطع الاتصال ما بين المقاتلين والقياده هو
ما يزيد همم ازمه الجيش الاوكراني في هذه
المنطقه العربيه رائد الاخضر شكرا جزيلا
لك
صحيفه ول ستريت جورنال اكدت في تقرير لها
ان ممثلين عن اداره الرئيس جو فايدن كشفوا
ان البنتاغون يواجه صعوبات في تزويد
اوكرانيا بانظمه استطلاع وضرب نموذجيه
للتصدي للطائرات المسيره من طراز فامباير
واضافت الصحيفه طبعا نقلا عن مصادرها ان
واشنطن كانت وعدت بتوريت هذا النوع من
الاسلحه في اغسطس الماضي حيث وقع
البنتاجون عقدا مع شركه التصنيع حارس
بقيمه تقدر ب 40 مليون دولار وهو ما لا
يكفي للايفاء بالكميات الكبيره التي
تحتاجها اوكرانيا وفقا للتقرير
وفي سياق التوتر بين واشنطن و موسكو كشفت
صحيفه عن معلومات بشان سفينه تجاريه روسيه
ليدي ار قالت انها تحمل علمتها اسلحه
مخباه زعمت ان شحنه هذه الاسلحه موجهه
للكرملين قالت الصحيفه عن مصادر ان
السفينه اوقفت
واوقفت اجهزه الارسال والاستقبال لديها
الشهر الماضي لتر في بناء سيمون تاون في
اكبر قاعده بحريه جنوب افريقيا سلطات جنوب
افريقيا لم تقدم اي معلومات عن حموله
السفينه التي تم تفريغها في القاعده مخاوف
امريكيه طرحها مسؤولون من ان تكون السفينه
والتي تخضع للعقوبات الامريكيه تحمل ذخائر
من روسيا وقد اكدت مصادر واستريت جورنال
المعلومات
اخذت مصادر العربيه ان حكومه طالبان في
ولايه بكلان اعطت اصحابها صالونات التجميل
النسائيه في الولايه الواقعه الشماليه
افغانستان مهله لمده 10 ايام
ليغلقوا محلاتهم حيث ان منطقه بخلاماري
عاصمه بكلان يوجد بها حوالي 20 صالون
تجميل نسائي كما امرت طالبان في منطقه
مزار شريف بولايه بلاخ منع الفتيات من
العمل في المحلات التجاريه
[موسيقى]
من افغانستان الى باكستان فقد وجه ولي
العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
بدراسه زياده الاستثمارات السعوديه داخل
باكستان والمعلن في الخامس والعشرين من
اغسطس الماضي لتصل الى 10 مليارات دولار
وفقا لوكاله الانباء السعوديه كما يدرس
الصندوق السعودي للتنميه زياده مبلغ
الوديعه المقدمه لصالح البنك المركزي
الباكستاني المعلن عنها في الثاني من
ديسمبر الماضي لتصل الى خمسه مليارات
دولار
هذا وقد فاز ولي العهد السعودي الامير
محمد بن سلمان بلقب القائد العربي الاكثر
تاثيرا عام 20 22 وذلك للعام الثاني على
التوالي وفقه استطلاع للراي اجرته قناه
روسيا اليوم والناطقه باللغه العربيه حصل
ولي العهد السعودي على نحو سبعه ملايين
و400 الف صوت من اجماله 12 مليون صوت شارك
في الاستفتاء ما يشكل 62.3 من الاصوات وهو
رقم قياسي في تاريخ استطلاعات الراي التي
تجريها روسيا اليوم في نهايه كل عام
قطط محكمه الاستئناف طرابلس الليبيه بقبول
الطعام ضد مذكره التفاهم الليبيه التركيه
حول التنقيب عن النفط والغاز قررت المحكمه
في جلستها بالشق المستعجل وقفه تنفيذ
الاتفاقيه
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
الكشف عن قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد
ترجيحات ببدا اضرابات وحركات احتجاجيه
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه وثائق سريه
وجدت في مكتب الرئيس الحالي في مركزه
للدراسات وتعود الى الفتره التي تسلم فيها
منصب نائب الرئيس وقد تعرض هذه الوثائق
للمساءله طبعا بتشجيع من الجمهوريه مجلس
النواب
سيناريو مكرر كان بطله الاول الرئيس
الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب عندما تم
العثور على وثائق سريه في منزله بالثوره
اما هذه المره ورئيس الحالي هو بطل المشهد
بعد ان كشف محامو بيض عددا من الوثائق
السريه في مكتبه بمركز ابحاث في واشنطن
تعود للفتره التي استلم فيها منصب نائب
الرئيس
العشر لم يتم التاكد من سريتها لكن قد يتم
اتهامه باساءه التعامل مع سجلات سريه ما
يخلق المشاكل الرئيس
وهو الذي خرج للتو من انتخابات التجديد
النصفي موقفا قد يدفع جمهوريه مجلس النواب
التي تدعمه مؤخرا بالمقار فيه الى فتحي
تحقيقا
ويؤثر على وزاره العدل فيما يجب ان
توجهاتهامات لترامب الذي اعلنترشحه للا
بادي 2004
اهميه لايجاد الوثائق مؤكدا ان
الديمقراطيين بالغوا في موقفهم بالتعامل
مع الوثائق السريه في منزله ترامب مقارنا
مع موقف بيضا
معه وقت اطول لم يكن ترامب في منصبه من
قبل وكان قد غدر للتو وخرج من منصبه
التروس متسائلا ما اذا كان مكتب التحقيقات
الفيدراليه سيداهم منازل
والبيت الابيض حتى في اشاره لمداهمه منزله
في فلوريدا عمر العربيه
المزيد معي من لندن مراسل العربيه مصطفى
زارو اهلا بك مصطفى خبرنا عن حجم الاقبال
هل لدينا ارقام او لا
ليست هناك ارقام يعني دقيقه حتى هذه
اللحظه لكن ما نعرفه ان هذا الكتاب يحتل
المرتبه الاولى في قوائم افضل الكتب مبيعا
على موقع امازون وبالتالي يعني سيكون
الاقبال ربما اكثر في وقت في وقت ما خصوصا
الذين يريدون ان يحصلوا على هذه النسخه من
احد
النتاجر همم
الموزعه عبر مختلف الاراضي المملكه
سالت شخصين وانا يعني انتظر هذه المقابله
وكان كان جوابهما انهم لن يعني نشتري هذا
الكتاب لانه اضر بسمعه الملكيه والاسره
الملكيه بالتحديد نظرا لما ااا سربه اولا
من سواء من خلال اللقاءات التي روجت لهذا
الكتاب او من خلال التسريبات والمقالات عن
ما جاء في هذا الكتاب وبالتالي لن يكون
لدى فئه على الاقل لدى فئه عمريه معينه
وخاصه ولكن الذين لا يتجوز يعني السنوات
الاربعين ربما لن يشتروا هذا الكتاب ولكن
هناك فئه يعني تهتم بما جاء في هذه التسرب
وتريد ان تعرف اكثر وخاصه فيما يتعلق
بالشجار بين الاميرين وهذه بالاضافه الى
ان همم بحسب التسجيلات بان همم يعني
الطلبه الاميران من والديهما الامير
تشارلز ااا عدم الزواج
بكميلا وبالاضافه الى همم يعني تسريبات
اخرى تتعلق
بالشباب الامير هذه الذي اثرت الكثير من
الجدل والضجه وغضب في نفس الوقت من قبل
يعني فئه معينه وخاصه من من قبل الذين
يدعمون الملكيه في المملكه المتحده ومصطفى
عندما تقول هذا الكلام هل من دراسات ترى
همم سبب اقبال هذه الفئه العمريه لهذا
الكتاب بمعنى اخر انه هو الفضول فقط
لمعرفه التفاصيل وانما نسبه من يعملون
اكثر ضد الملكيه اصبح متسع ربما
على الارجح بان اولئك الذين يميلون لشراء
هذا الكتاب سواء الذين يحبون يعني الثنائي
الامير هاري وميغان او اولئك الذين يريدون
فقط الفضول ومعرفه الشجار داخل الاسره
الملكيه التي عاده لم نسمع بها من قبل الى
ان جاء زواج الامير هاري بميغان وما تلاه
من لغت سواء داخل القصر الملكي بحسب
التسريبات للامير هذه او من طرف اولئك
الذين لا يريدون دعم همم
الصمت دائما ما يكون هو جواد
القصر الملكي في كل هذه الامور خاصه تلك
التي لها علاقات يعني او تسريبات تسيء
سمعت الاسره الملكيه وبالتالي الكلام كله
لي هاري ولا جواد من او رد فعل من القصر
الملكي العربيه
نبقى في بريطانيا
او القضاء البريطانيه التاريخيه التي
حاولت خلالها الشركه اطلاق اول صاروخ الى
الفضاء الخارجي طبعا انطلاقه من الاراضي
البريطانيه بقت بالفشل بسبب خلل
ظهر قبيله وصول الصاروخ الى المدارس
بريطانيا تسعى لتكون تاسعه دوله في العالم
تتمكن من وضع اقمار الصناعيه في المدارس
لكن تجربتها الفضائيه الاخيره باءت بالفشل
طائره كوزمج جيرل التابعه لبرج اقلعت من
مطار نيوكي في جنوب غرب انجلترا حامله
صاروخ الفضائيا طوله 21 مترا
الصاروخ ارتفع 35 الف قدم فوق سطح المحيط
الاطلسي لكن خلل حال دون وصوله الى هدفه
ويمثل هذا الفشل ضربه اخرى لطموحات الفضاء
الاوروبيه من جهتها عاده الطائره المملوكه
للملياردير البريطانيه ريتشارد رانسون الى
المطار بسلام
[موسيقى]
رجحت مذكره لجهاز الاستخبارات الفرنسي بدا
اضرابات وايضا تحركات احتجاجيه قد تمتد
لعده ايام تؤدي الى شلل في قطاعات بعينها
وذلك بالتزامن مع عزم رئيسه الوزراء
الفرنسيه اليزابيث بورن الكشف عن تفاصيل
مشروع قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد المثير
للجدل المساء اليوم تنص احدى مواد القانون
على رفع سن التقاعد من 62 عام حاليا الى
64 او 65 عاما وفي الوقت ذاته تتجه 8
نقابات عماليه لتحديد حجم وتوقيت التحرك
الاحتجاجي واصدار موقف مشترك فورا انت
نهائي خطابي رئيسه الوزراء
الى اخبار الخامسه الرياضيه مع زياد زياد
تفضل
[موسيقى]
نا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام اعرب العديد من
اعضاء اللجنه التنفيذيه للاتحاد الفرنسي
لكره القدم مع الرغبهم برحيل الرئيس نايلو
جريت من منصبه وحسب راديو مونت كارلو فان
اعضاء اللجنه التنفيذيه سيعقدون اجتماعا
طارئه للاتحاد الفرنسي من اجل اقناع
بالاستقاله وكان رئيس الاتحاد الفرنسي
اعتذر يوم امس عن تصريحات سابقا انتقد
فيها اللاعب دوري السابق زين الدين زيدان
كما وجهت وكيل الاعمال سونيا السويد
اتهامات مباشره لرئيس الاتحاد الفرنسي
لكره القدم لوغريت بالقيامي بسلوك جنسيه
غير لائق وواجهه اتهامات وكاله الاعمال في
حديث لها مع صحيفه لكيب من جانبها هناء
وزيره الرياضه الفرنسيه ايميلي اوديا عبر
حسابها في تويتر وكيله الاعمال على
شجاعتها انها ستواصل العمل على رحيل رئيس
الاتحاد الفرنسي عن منصبه الذي يشغله منذ
العام 20011
توجد متسابقه الفرنسي سبستيان لوبي لقبي
المرحله التاسعه مره لذكار المقام حاليا
في السعوديه
وبدات المرحله من العاصمه الرياض الى
منطقه حرض بمسافه وصلت الى 686 كيلومترا
فيما وصلت مسافه المرحله الخاصه الى 300
و58 كلم
ويتصدر المتسابق القطري ناصر العطيه
الترتيب العام للمسابقات او السباق بفارق
مريحا اقرب ملاحقه في اطار سعيه للاحتفاظ
باللقب
يا حلوه الهلال الليله ضيفا على الرائد في
مباراه المقدمه من الجوله الخامسه عشر من
الدوري السعودي لكره القدم وتم تقديمه هذه
المباراه نظرا لارتباط الهلال بالمشاركه
في بطوله كاس العالم للانديه المقبله و
سيدخل الهلال المباراه بمعنويات عاليه
خاصه بعد فوزها على الاتحاد في الجوله
الماضيه من الدوري السعودي ويملك الهلال
25 نقطه مقابل 15 نقطه لفريق الرائد
وفي مباراه مؤجله من الدوري السعودي لكره
القدم تعادل الشباب مع الاتحاد بهدف لكل
منهما تفاصيل لهذه المباراه الثانيه
[موسيقى]
الشباب يستضيف الاتحاد على استاد الامير
فيصل بن فهد في الرياض
اصحاب الضيافه يفتتحون فرص اللقاء بهبري
يرسل كره بعيده عن مرمى الاتحاد
[تصفيق]
البرازيلي يرد بهذه الكره التي مرت
بمحاذاه القائم
عبد الرحمن
جاريه الملعب في الجهه الاخرى صراع في
منطقه جزاء الاتحاد بين باهابري واحمد
حجازي ينتهي بركله جزاء شبابيه وبطاقه
صفراء للمدافع المصري
جونكا يسدد بطريقه متقنه وينجح في احراز
هدف للشباب
[تصفيق]
الاتحاد يحاول العوده سريعا ومعركه
بالاقدام امام مرمى الشباب تنتهي بتسديده
من حجازي داخل المرمى
الطائر ينقذ الاتحاد من هدف المحقق
بعدها بقليل حجازي يتدخلوا لحمايه مرمى
الضيوف
غوانكا يتفنن في اللقطه ورايه التسلل
حاضره
اخرى للكره
فرصه
اه في الشوط الثاني كارلوس جونيور يهدر
فرصه شبابيه جديده
[موسيقى]
عبد الرحمن العبود يسدد كره بعيده عن
الشباك
وهنا الرايه ترتفع ضد محاوله حمض الله
[موسيقى]
الاشتباك بين الفريقين يستمر دون تغيير في
النتيجه والحكم يطلق سافته بتعادل الشباب
والاتحاد بهدف لكل منهما هدى زين الدين
العربي
لحساب المجموعه الثانيه لبطوله كاس الخليج
لكره القدم يلتقي بعد قليل المنتخب القطري
مع نظيره البحريني ويملك المنتخبان ثلاث
نقاط لكل منهما الفريقان لقياس سبعه عشر
مره في 24 نسخه من البطوله الخليجيه حيث
تغلبت البحرين في خمس مباريات وفازت قطر
في اربعه منها وتعادل المنتخبان في 8
مناسبات
من جانبه تعرض المنتخب السعودي للخساره
امام نظيره العراقي بهدفين دون مقابل
ضمنها منافسات المجموعه الاولى لبطوله كاس
الخليج لكره القدم بهذه النتيجه ارتفع
رصيد المنتخب العراقي الى اربع نقاط
لصدارات المجموعه ومتقدما بفارق الاهداف
عن المنتخب العماني لما تجمد رصيد المنتخب
السعودي عند ثلاث نقاط في المرتبه الثالثه
للمجموعات الاولى
نهايه اخبار الرياضه شكرا لكم على حسن
المتابعه وعوده اليك ميسون
[موسيقى]
اوروبا في منظمه الصحه العالميه هانز كلوب
ان المنظمه لا تتوقع ان تؤدي زياده حالات
الاصابه بقبض نايتين في الصين الى تاثير
كبير على الوضع الوبائي في اوروبا
فان الزياده في نوعين من الطفرات
الفيروسيه المنتشره في الصين هي تلك التي
شهدت بالفعل في اوروبا واماكن اخرى نشارك
وجهه النظر الحاليه للمركز الاوروبي
لمكافحه الامراض بان الارتفاع المسجل في
الصين ليس من المتوقع ان يؤثر بشكل كبير
على الوضع الوبائي 2019 في المنطقه
الاوروبيه في هذا الوقت
بعد توقف منصه تيك توك عن العمل في الاردن
اكد الناطق الرسمي باسم الحكومه الاردنيه
فيصل الشبول اكد ان هناك حوار تقني قانوني
مع شركه تيك توك متابعه
في الاردن
لتلك المساحه الكبيره التي حاضت بها
المنصه من حياه ابنائه واليوم يرفض ابنائه
غيابها اما هو فكان من اكثر المرحبين بهذا
الغياب
مواصله ايقاف هذا التطبيق لانه زي ما حكيت
مكان لنشر التفاهه مكان للتحريض مكان
للخطاء لخطاب الكراهيه ومكان لنشر
الاكاذيب فيها اشياء سلبيه فيها اشياء
ايجابيه
وبظهر لكل شخص حسب اهتماماته يعني
حول ارتفاع اسعار المحروقات في الاردن
كانت السبب في توقفها منذ ثلاثه اسابيع
وما بين رافض ومؤيد انقسمت اراء الشارع بس
نفسي افهم ايش دخل التيك توك بالي عم
بتصير ليشطبوا يعني تكتب كان شيء كثير
بسلي
على الهاتف لكنه لا يعمل الا ان البعض ذهب
لمواقع في بي ان لفك الحظر ومتابعه من
الصدته التي اثر غيابها على وجوه اعتمدتها
لشهره ومصدر للرز
يزعل يشيل الخط الارضي او بس يزعل مني
يعني تقدر مثلا
[موسيقى]
في الاردن
لا تزال عمليات الترميم قائمه في مجمع
المباني الحكوميه بالعاصمه البرازيليه بعد
اقتحامه من قبل محتجين الموالينا للرئيس
السابق جير بولو
[موسيقى]
وصلنا